[Music]
if you are looking to run queries on
data not already part of public or
shared data sets
you must first load your data into
bigquery bigquery accepts data in
several formats
this video will cover how to load data
from a csv file on your local machine
into bigquery using the web ui
this process requires a google cloud
platform project with billing enabled
within your project you may take
advantage of the google cloud free tier
and bypass cost by staying within the
tier limits for cloud storage and
bigquery
loading data into bigquery via the web
ui can be done two ways
first by loading the data directly from
your local machine or second by using
google cloud storage as an intermediary
direct uploads from your computer using
the bigquery web ui
are limited to 10 megabytes for this
reason this video will focus on loading
data into bigquery by way of google
cloud storage which doesn't have this
limit get started in the bigquery web ui
identify the data set to which you would
like to add the new table
if using an existing data set note the
data location
the data location will be needed in a
future step
you need to create a new data set do so
now
to create a new data set select the
project name in the left-hand nav
and then click the create data set
button name the data set
choose the data set location and then
click create data set
the new data set will shortly appear in
the left-hand nav
next navigate to cloud storage by typing
storage into the search bar in the
console
when you arrive click the create bucket
button
name your bucket
then choose the location you must choose
a location for your cloud storage bucket
in the same region as the location of
the bigquery data set
the bucket can be either a
multi-regional bucket or a regional
bucket in the same region as the data
set
one exception you can load data in a
us-based data set from any region
since you are creating this bucket for
the sole reason to transfer the data
into bigquery
save on egress charges by choosing the
exact same location as your destination
data set and bigquery
in this demo that is multi-region us
choose the standard storage class then
click create
now you may click the upload files
button to select the file you want to
upload
or simply drag the file from your
desktop onto the google cloud storage
browser
once the upload finishes navigate back
to the bigquery web ui
select your data set and click create
table
choose google cloud storage as your
source
click browse
double-click on the storage bucket
and select your data object
the file format should update
automatically
provide a table name
you can either provide the schema
details or click the box to auto detect
the schema
at this time you may choose to partition
and cluster your data
a video outlining the hows and whys of
partitioning and clustering is linked in
the video description below
if your csv file has a header row
display the advanced options and add the
number of header rows in the header rows
to skip field
there are also several other options you
can choose including alternative field
delimiters based on your file
now click create table a load job will
be created
when the job finishes you can view the
table schema
details and a preview of the data now
your table is ready to be queried
click query table and a pre-loaded query
statement will appear in the query
editor
which you can begin editing directly
before diving into the data
consider if you would like to delete the
file you originally loaded into google
cloud storage
depending on your situation it can also
be useful to keep it as a backup
both cloud storage and bigquery storage
have separate pricing
so be sure to review the pricing
documentation linked below
thanks for watching and happy analyzing